infinity war was nuts  but this one is going to be your finest  hour we're in the end game you know  Adams wiped out 50% of all living  creatures these are the highest stakes  that the Avengers have ever faced this  is the fight of our lives this has been  work stood I know it is cuz I don't know  what I'm gonna do if it doesn't every  time you think marbles pulled every  single trick out of the bag  they actually saved the best stuff for  this morning this is the end of the  firework show the grand finale soit Elia  is insane you just don't know what to  expect  I guarantee you there is no way anybody  could guess what's gonna happen  where's the Avengers we gotta finish  this  tickets on sale now